today on the matt walsh show it finally
happened one brave left-wing journalist
watched and reviewed what is a woman and
uh they didn't like it shockingly also
the january 6 hearings were held last
night and nobody cares i certainly don't
more shocking and damning revelations
about the law enforcement response or
lack thereof in yuvaldi texas plus a
former nba star opens up about his quote
unquote trans child parents sue
instagram for the damage that it did to
their daughter and our daily
cancellation old navy tries to virtue
signal to the body positivity crowd and
it backfires in a major and hilarious
way we'll talk about all that and more
today on the matt walsh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we all know that gas prices are
insanely high right now but there is
some good news it's an incredible app
everybody who buys gas needs to know
about it's called upside my listeners
are earning cashback for every gallon of
gas every time they fill up just
download the free upside app in the app
store or google play right now use promo
code walsh for 25 cents per gallon or
more on your first fill up cash back
don't pay full price of the pump anymore
get cash back using upside just download
the app for free and use promo code
walsh for 25 cents per gallon or more on
your first tank and it's not just for
gas you can earn cash back at grocery
stores restaurants uh with your takeout
also anything you can get cash back on
all that you can cash out anytime to
your bank account or you can even get an
e-gift card for select retailers and
brands just download the free upside app
and use promo code walsh to get 25 cents
per gallon or more cash back on your
first tank uh look we're all looking for
ways to save money at uh the gas pump
and it seems like it's all downside but
there is some upside it's called the
upside app just make sure when you go
there use my promo code walsh again
that's the upside app and use code walsh
well as you know the left has tried its
best to ignore my film what is a woman
even as it has dominated the
conversation become the most popular
streaming movie in the country this
month according to rotten tomatoes um
that's not to say they haven't
criticized the documentary they have
it's just that they they've criticized
it from a safe distance and without
actually watching it first but it's come
to my attention that one person on the
left
or one left and one left-wing
publication um did actually watch the
movie and just this one as far as i know
or they claim to have watched it anyway
and i would be remiss if i did not
acknowledge this brave soul and honor
her for her efforts but i can only give
full credit if she watches the film and
then engages with it and criticizes it
honestly and it's on this last step that
the writer aaron rook of the publication
lgbtq nation kind of tends to falter
still i think it could be worthwhile to
go through this critique because it
shows once again i think just how
totally flimsy and bereft of logic the
other side of this discussion truly is
while trying to debunk the film she only
manages to prove most of the major
points in the film as we'll see
so rook delivers her commentary in a
review titled quote the dangerous
deception of matt walsh's documentary
what is a woman we watched matt walsh's
anti-trans propaganda so you don't have
to spoiler alert it's full of
transphobic lies
that sounds pretty bad full of
transphobic lies now before delving into
what she claims are the myths propagated
by the film rook writes quote the film
is slickly produced
thank you and includes interviews with
some reputable sources but walsh seems
more interested in exposing these
efforts that these experts than actually
learning from them he also allows his
anti-transgender sources to spout off
dangerous disinformation unchecked
now that's incorrect i was not
interested in exposing them and i did
not expose them they exposed themselves
figuratively anyway i mean one guy in
san francisco literally exposed himself
but as for the so-called experts they
exposed the vacuousness of their own
worldview i didn't do anything except
provide them a forum for this
self-destruction uh and that's all we
did that was the whole point we just
asked questions she then proceeds to
list the film's most malignant myths now
let's go through these
these are the myths propagated
in uh my film it says myth
trans people who medically transition
are at increased risk of suicide
and she could she explains in an effort
to portray gender transition as
dangerous the film includes the
assertion that trans the transition
makes people suicidal this claim is
likely rooted in a misinterpretation of
the research promoted by
anti-transgender psychiatrist dr paul
mchugh in a 2014 wall street journal
op-ed but the 2011 swedish study he
references was not designed to evaluate
the efficacy of gender affirmation
surgeries and its authors caution
against such an interpretation trans
journalist kristen williams interviewed
lead author dr cecilia dejing who
expressed her frustration at the ways in
which her research had been
misrepresented quote i've even seen
professors use my work to support
ridiculous claims i've often had to
respond myself by commenting on articles
speaking with journalists and talking
about this problem at conferences people
who misuse the study always omit the
fact that the study clearly states that
it's not an evaluation of gender
dysphoria treatment if we look at the
literature we find that several recent
studies include a conclude that wpath
standards of care compliant treatment
decrease gender dysphoria and improve
mental health
okay now
the fact that the authors of the study
the swedish study
were not trying to prove that gender
affirmation surgery quote unquote big
scare quotes around that increases
suicidality
and yet they proved it anyway
only makes the results more compelling
not less
that study no matter what the authors of
the study would prefer or how they'd
like us to read the data
clearly shows that trans people are the
most suicidal a decade after the surgery
again
according to the author of the study as
this article points out this one author
that's not what she was trying to prove
that's not what she set out to do and
yet she proved it
so this is these are results that cut
against the biases apparently of the
people who conducted the study which
just makes the results all the more
convincing
this is what the data shows planet plain
as day
and that's why in this attempt to debunk
the quote myth the writer never actually
says outright that the claim about
suicide alley is wrong she she cautions
against misinterpretation but does not
attempt to refute it because she can't
and that's because the data is clear
in fact every study that's ever been
done by anyone anywhere shows that trans
people pre-op post-op no op affirmed
unaffirmed no matter what
have suicide rates significantly higher
than the general population
this clearly indicates that there is
something deeper going on inside the
mind that it's a problem in the mind
which is why surgeries can't fix it and
as this study shows don't fix it
you know what you know notice what else
our friend aaron doesn't do
she doesn't provide any contrary
evidence at all this is a theme that
will continue throughout the article and
it continues with with any attempt to
debunk my movie or to debunk any of the
the arguments that we make on the um
anti-gender ideology side uh they never
prevent they never present any evidence
to prove their assertions she debunks
the claims in my film without really
refuting them and without providing any
evidence to support her position
so kind of a rough start start but let's
see if things maybe get a little bit
better continuing um
it says quote myth gender affirming
surgeries are experimental and dangerous
she explains some of the worst
fear-mongering comes from transgender
man scott nugent who is on a crusade
against medical transition for youth in
the film nugent says that gender
affirming surgery comes with a 67
complication risk and shows the scar
from his phalloplasty related skin graft
for dramatic effect
phalloplasty a complex procedure is not
without risk of complications however
rates are much lower than the 67
nugent claims and vary depending on the
approach taken by the surgeon a 2017
study found that rates of urethral
complications were between 31.5 and 32.8
depending on the approach it's also not
the most commonly sought transition
related surgery trans masculine
individuals are much more likely to seek
a double mastectomy aka top surgery
which has a complication rate of about
12 percent and many trans people don't
seek any surgical interventions which
casts doubt on his claim that for every
child convinced to transition big pharma
rakes in 1.3 million okay
now
actually
the 67 figure
may be vastly understating it depending
on what study you look at and also
depending on how you define complication
but let's just go with her figure for
the sake of argument
she's trying to debunk the myth
quote unquote that gender affirming
surgeries are experimental and dangerous
and she does so by favorably citing a
study that says rates of complication
are over 30 percent
that's extraordinarily high 30 percent
complication right
she's taking the very low end of the
complication rate okay the most generous
study she could find
and she still must admit it's a rate at
a minimum at best of over 30 percent
and this proves that it's
not dangerous
how so
and how in the world could this prove
that it's not experimental
she takes refuge in the fact that double
mastectomies have only only a 12 percent
complication rate still very high but
she ignores the fact that the primary
complication with cutting off a woman's
healthy breasts is that
you've cut off a woman's healthy breasts
the complication is that you've removed
a piece of her body a piece of her and
you've done it on the theory that will
help her to be a man even though she can
never be a man and chopping off her
breast will bring her no closer to
manhood than she was when she still had
them
the fact that there are allegedly only
quote unquote additional complications
and 12 percent of cases does not rescue
you from this fact it's the surgery
itself that's the problem
even if everything goes
perfectly well when you're cutting the
breasts off of a off of a woman
you're still cutting her breasts off and
that's the issue you are removing
healthy body parts and often you're
doing this to young girls who would not
even be allowed to legally get tattoos
because they've been judged too young
for it
finally it's insisted that many trans
people don't get surgeries which she
says cast doubt on the claim that every
child who transitions rakes in 1.3
million for big pharma now with this
rebuttal the writer is simply pretending
i guess that hormone pills and puberty
blockers don't exist
because obviously when we're talking
about the money that big pharma makes
off of all of this we're primarily
talking about the pills and the
injections
but okay we're just that none of that
exists apparently okay
incredible
now that concludes basically the the
closest thing to an attempt at a real
rebuttal that you'll find in the article
though she does continue listing myths
while the debunking efforts get lazier
and lazier as she goes along she
addresses the myth in the film that
quote real transgender people are rare
and she does this by pointing to a ucla
study that claims point six percent of
the population is trans now
that would still qualify as rare by any
definition of the word rare that i've
ever heard point six percent but she
then she then notes that a recent pew
study found that 5
of young people identify as trans
but that doesn't refute anything we say
in the film in fact
we claim in the film that trans
identification is skyrocketing among
young people she's agreeing with us not
refuting us that's our point
okay so again using using the numbers
presented 0.6 general population
fine that's still
insanely high but fine what point six
percent
percent for people under 30.
how in the world do you explain that
well our point is that this astronomical
rise is due to social contagions and
indoctrination
she makes no attempt to address that
next she tries to debunk my claim that
children can't choose their own gender
and she does that by assuring us that in
fact
it's quote widely accepted by pediatric
professionals that children can choose
their genders
that's it it's widely accepted so move
on
now it's true it is widely accepted and
one of the main points of our film is to
reveal that this wide acceptance is not
rooted in any coherent underlying logic
like i totally agree that it's widely
accepted that's one of the reasons we
made the movie
but we're trying to discover is why is
it so widely accepted
and what we discovered is that it's not
widely accepted based on any kind of
rational
logical basis unless you want to talk
about profit motive as a rational
logical base of basis
finally she seeks to debunk the myth
quote unquote that transgender
identities are a modern western
invention
and she claims that on this topic quote
walsh hasn't done his homework
well i literally went to africa
i mean it's hard harder to do more
homework than that on something like
this the writer on the other hand did
much more extensive research by googling
it for five seconds
and from her googling she learned about
native american two-spirit identities
and the hedra in india and she says that
these are examples of non-western trans
identities
the problem is that the two-spirit
designation was invented by lgbt
activists in america in the 90s so it is
itself a modern western invention okay
the comanche on the great plains weren't
going around calling themselves
two-spirit and transgender didn't exist
as for the
alleged variation in india the groups
you refer to are not traditionally seen
as trans in the way that we use the term
this is a spiritual concept often
referring to eunuchs who undergo
castration rituals
this is not the same as the belief that
men can actually be
women okay so this is a really important
point to prove
that transgenderism is not uniquely
modern in western you would have to find
non-western cultures where they believe
men can actually literally be women and
women can literally be men
not spiritually or figuratively or
performatively but literally
you'd have to find somewhere that
believes a pregnant person can be a man
an actual man
and you'd have to prove that this
culture had this idea came up with it on
its own and that it wasn't introduced to
them by westerners
now um you won't find that because it
doesn't exist i'll just make it easy for
you not going to find it doesn't exist
just as you won't find any actual
rebuttals in this rebuttal or in any
other rebuttal of what is a woman
but she did watch the movie at least
next time she should probably watch it
with her eyes open and the earplugs out
she might actually learn something
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know the value of the minivan pickup
sedan or whatever you drive probably
appreciated significantly last year take
care of your automotive investment and
keep more of your money by buying the
auto parts you need to remain maintain
and repair your vehicle at rockauto.com
rockauto.com only sells auto parts and
related tools and they've been doing it
for over 20 years so they know what
they're doing their unique intuitive
catalog includes photos specs and
installation tips that make it easy to
choose the correct parts for your
specific vehicle
they not only have the auto parts you
need but they'll give you a selection of
trusted name brands to choose from you
can pick breaks that match how you use
your vehicle whether that's for towing
racing or just commuting to work you can
get suspension exhaust air conditioning
other kits that provide all the parts
you need for successful repair
rockauto.com has lots of parts that you
might expect would only be available at
car dealerships if they're available at
all parts like the fan inside your seat
that
cools cools your tush rockauto.com
prices are always reliably low the
prices make it affordable for customers
to keep their daily driver and classic
safely on the road so go to rockauto.com
for your auto parts and write walsh in
their how did you hear about us box so
they know that i sent you again that's
rockauto.com
um let's see here so
the
january 6th
commission was last night
and uh
i just don't care at all i mean i'm i'm
so bored by the story i had a whole
thing here i have articles i was gonna
i really don't care
i'm not even gonna talk about it i i
this this story is a it's an affront to
me i think as a
as a news commentator as someone who has
i have to make my living
talking about the news
and current events
and the way they keep cycling back to
january 6th
and i'm supposed to keep finding things
to say about it i got nothing else to
say about it
i i have nothing else to say
it happened
uh
i wish it shouldn't have happened it was
a bad thing you know it was it was
stupid it was very stupid thing to go
rushing into the capitol
taking selfies at nancy pelosi's desk
very very stupid um
that's it that's really all there is to
say about it
um
and i i certainly am not interested in
hearing these lawmakers
reliving their trauma
talking about how traumatized they are
it's just it's so
i'm bored i'm bored to death by it i
really am
and i think everybody else is too
there's just there's no there's no
interest in this i mean they they put
this thing on prime time
intentionally
you know because they've done the
hearings before they've done how many
hearings have they done on this on this
stupid thing already they've done many
hearings and a lot of times they're
doing them you know during the day and
nobody's watching no one cares no one's
talking about it and so then they
thought you know what let's let's wait
till everyone's home from work and we'll
put it on prime time prime time viewing
and then people care and still no one
cares
especially me so moving on here's
something i do care about uh police
officers this is from daily wire police
officers waited outside robb elementary
school for more than an hour despite
being armed with knowledge that there
were still children trapped inside with
the gunman still alive and possibly
wounded
according to an article published
yesterday
detailing an investigation
undertaken by the new york times into
the widely panned police response to the
tragic shooting in uvalde texas body
camera footage and documentation
suggests that the initial claims made by
law enforcement were false
uvalde school district top cop pedro
arendando who was in charge at the scene
of the shooting reported that he was
unaware students were dialing 911 from
inside the classroom one even taking a a
phone from her deceased teacher in order
to do so but the times report suggests
otherwise
quote
heavily armed officers delayed
confronting a gunman in uh in uvalde
texas for more than an hour despite
supervisors at the scene being told
that some trapped with him in two
elementary classrooms were in need of
medical treatment and this is according
to new uh video footage so they straight
up lied okay they were told
that there are
that there are still
people alive in this classroom people
who need medical treatment
desperately and they still waited an
hour
instead the documents show they waited
for protective equipment
to lower the risk to law enforcement
officers
so it might seem a lot of this is it
might seem like the the things that we
already knew
but these are um
now we have actual evidence i mean it
seemed almost immediately that something
uh that the story we were told by law
enforcement was not true and then we
started getting
we you know we started seeing videos of
parents outside the school desperately
wanting to go in we see the cops kind of
standing around and the information's
trickling in
and it trickles in in a way that allows
them to try to massage the story in a
certain way to make them
to um you know mitigate
their own fault here
but now with the body camera footage 911
records
it's 100 clear
that the this lunatic was in the
classroom with children
children were still alive in that
classroom
he continued shooting during the course
of that hour executing these
kids
um
others were laying there needing medical
attention
how many died
because they weren't getting medical
attention in the first hour we don't
know that yet
maybe eventually we'll find that out
and now we know that they they were
standing outside largely because
they were waiting for protective
equipment so that they didn't get hurt
going in there
this is the uh
this is the biggest law enforcement
scandal of all time i think
i can't think of anything bigger than
this
and i i this is
just for the sake of uh obviously for
the sake of justice but also for the
sake of
civilized society
you know so we can stave off the the
chaos and anarchy that we're already
seeing in so many cities uh if we want
to if we don't want that to get a lot
worse
then the people responsible for this
need to not just be fired but put
imprisoned i mean you need to start
arresting people
the officers that were there on the
scene waiting outside they should all be
under arrest
and the police
the the
law enforcement official who was in
charge there
lying about it should all be under
arrest
i mean this is this is necessary because
if you don't do that
then it's just going to be impossible
for people to have any trust
in law enforcement i mean in order in
order to maintain or restore any sort of
trust in our institutions including law
enforcement you need to hold people
accountable in a situation like this
all right
so we told you about moving on to this
we told you about redskins coach jack
del rio who tweeted something yesterday
a couple days ago saying that the blm
riots were worse than january 6th which
they were
uh and then he doubled down in a press
conference and but then he then he
folded and as as i learned live on the
air yesterday very disappointed to learn
i was i was i was trying to give him
credit
as one of the very few guys in a
situation like this says something
people are upset then he does a press
conference he doubles down in the press
conference
very rarely happens
and the thing is i don't even care what
the situation is what you said in this
case it happens that he said something
that was true and i agree with but even
if even if he hadn't
i don't even care what it is
you say something people are upset and
then you double down
i have respect for that
but then uh shortly after doubling down
he decides to fold and apologize
apologize to all the people that were
hurt by his tweet you know because
there are a lot of people out there who
were deeply hurt because jack del rio
almost nobody
unless you're unless you're an avid
football fan you have no idea who jack
del rio is
and if you are an avid football fan
you've heard you know who he is but you
certainly don't
there's there's no opinion he could
offer that's going to cause any
emotional or physical pain to you
but he apologizes to the people that he
hurt
and um the question is will that apology
save him and we already know the answer
to that so here's yahoo sports derek
johnson the president of the naacp
called for the resignation or dismissal
of washington commanders defensive
coordinator jack del rio for his
wednesday comments about january 6th
attack on the us capitol
he says it's time for jack del rio to
resign or be terminated his comments
could not have been more offensive and
ignorant the january 6 insurrection
insurrection an attempted coup was far
more than a dust up each day we learned
more and more and just how close our
democracy came to autocracy
downplaying the insurrection by
comparing it to nationwide protests
which are in response to a public
lynching is twisted you can't coach a
majority black team while turning your
back on the black community it's time
for you to pack up and step off the
field so
the the apology was it's not that okay
he had an opinion
he expressed it
and then a day later he he reinforces
that opinion
doubles down on it
and then a couple hours later he's
apologizing did he realize that this
opinion that he's held this entire time
in a couple hours after that press
conference did he realize he was wrong
in the opinion
he was incorrect no
so he knows that he's right about what
he said but he apologized anyway to
avoid exactly this but it doesn't matter
because it doesn't matter if you
apologize it makes no it actually makes
no difference whatsoever
it is not going to have any effect on
the backlash
the people who want to fire you for your
opinion are still going to want you
fired whether you apologize or not
you could you could drop to your knees
in tears and beg them
beg them tearfully
to accept your apologize apology and to
let you keep your job it will not make a
difference
uh i wanted to play this clip also espn
of course they're very offended about
this and they're talking a lot about
this this gives them a chance you know
to do what they love to do which is to
talk about anything but sports so see if
you can make heads or tails of this
here's ryan clark a
former nfl player
and uh now nfl analyst and here he is uh
giving his take on on this controversy
for me the insensitive insensitivity in
which he approached it um when you're
talking about these protests if you're
speaking after jacob blake they're
people that lost their lives kyle
rittenhouse killed two people during
that protest there were
officers out there with ar-15s or
officers out there with assault rifles
policing the people who were protesting
and so now when you look at a person in
jack the real that has to sit in the
room in washington that is 85 percent
african-american and he and you have to
know as a player he is either not aware
or doesn't care enough about the people
he works with or the people or
communities they come from to be smart
enough not to say this
my problem and issue is when you're
talking about what jack del rio is
saying he's saying this that one wrong
is better because of the people involved
now you can think that's because those
people think like him or feel like him
or support the same things that he
supports or you can think that's because
those people look like him many of the
people in the rooms jack de rio coaches
in don't look like him
i just uh most of that's basically
incoherent and these people
like sports analysts not all of them
many of them are so
stupid
um
and he i watch this whole clip of him
and he just rambles like what are you
even trying to say
what i did pick up on though is the
insensitivity of the harmful language
this is a formal football this guy was
on i think he played defense for the
pittsburgh steelers
okay this guy's playing defense he's
he's hitting people for a living
maybe that's part of the reason why he
can't string together a coherent
sentence anymore but this is what he
does for a living and now and now he's
on tv what the hell happened
to uh i know it's a standard complaint
these days but
now you have football players
he was being insensitive in his language
his opinion was
harmful my god man have some
self-respect
um and
how does this have anything to do with
race what's racist about it well of
course there's no way to explain that
whatsoever
um this has his his opinion that express
had nothing to do with with race
obviously but somehow naacp is chiming
in
so if you're against rioting then that's
racist
i mean that's you're you're linking so
to to oppose rioting has happened in
2020 in cities across the country that
is an anti-black
opinion
if anything that seems like the rather
kind of a racist
claim to make
um we'll stay in the kind of in the
sports world here or at least former
sports stars this is also from daly wire
says former nba star dwyane wade told
cnn that he fears for his transgender
child zaya
and disagrees with legislation that
would make gender affirming procedures
on children illegal
now dwyane wade is married to gabrielle
union
who is a a hollywood actress
and they have it was a okay this is this
is a boy
who at a very young age they declared is
is actually a girl
um and like so many of these parents
you know it's bad enough that they're
transitioning their child but also of
course they have to tell the whole world
about it
which in this is intentional that also
has the effect of
cementing that child in that identity
that false identity
because once you've taken this little
kid and doesn't know any better uh and
then and you're parading
him around to the entire world say look
at
this
well he can't back away from it now
you've made him into a
into an activist
you made him into a leader of a movement
anyway here he is on cnn
talking a little bit about this about
his his fears you know as as the parent
of a quote trans child he's deeply
afraid let's find out why
i mean just overnight louisiana enacted
an anti-trans sports ban it's not the
first state to do so the governor there
called it discriminatory distressing
and i wonder what your reaction is in
your message to lawmakers and states
where these bans are
are happening you know you're you you
guys are going through this in your own
family and i wonder what you think yeah
i i to me it's a it's a
it's a joke i mean this is our life we
live this
and so when you're out there making
rules and if you're not experiencing
this if you're not living this and
you're just out there signing away and
making laws that's not right that's a
joke like come and live come and live a
day in my world with my daughter come
and see how it is to walk through this
world as as her
right like
like i i just think like we we're losing
we we're losing our humane like we we're
losing our the human side of us
um and it's is as sad as it is is as
blessed as my daughter is to have
parents who who can support her i'm
still afraid every moment she leaves our
house and not just because of gun gun
violence but because of the way that
people perceive her
in this world right
yeah well dwayne
you know i we we can't really walk in
the shoes of of your daughter
or understand what it's like to be your
daughter
because your daughter doesn't exist
that's not your daughter that's your son
okay that's a boy
and
he has you know something else
and this is something that's uh
scott nugent said in our film what is a
woman
that i thought was
like everything else in that interview
is very well put and very powerful
she said that you you don't have the
right to do this
you do not have the right to do this to
your child you do not have the right to
transition your child you don't have
that right
you don't have that
right okay you don't have the right to
make that decision for your child
and don't sit here and tell me that your
child made that decision because your
child did not
children can't make decisions like that
they can't consent to that
they literally cannot
they don't have the ability to do it
which is why i'm pretty sure
that if your
son
wanted to
well you mentioned gun violence
should he be allowed to go buy a gun
at this age
should it be legal for him to go buy a
gun oh no why not
okay why shouldn't 12 year olds be
allowed to buy guns explain to me
explain to me why 12 year old can't buy
a gun
see you can't explain it
you cannot explain it without without
saying something about how about their
their lack of psychological
and neurological development
okay whatever explanation you give for
why 12 year olds shouldn't be allowed to
buy guns it's going to have something to
do with the fact that they're not fully
developed in their brains uh they can't
be trusted they're they're immature
they're reckless they don't think far
enough into the future
that's your answer right that's your
reason
yeah well that's also why they can't
choose their own genders of course
um let's see okay so this one i i just
saw this now before before we went on
the air so this is from
the website bounding into comics and
they mentioned something about uh what
is a woman here they say so letterboxed
is a social platform that allegedly
allows users to post and share their
opinions about movies whether new or old
however social media users noticed that
something was radically different about
the review list for what is a woman
namely there are no reviews
letterbox has hidden
okay listen to this letter letter box
now this is again this is a site
uh i guess
kind of like rotten tomatoes except on
this site
it's a special emphasis on
you know users raiding
the film
so letterbox has hidden all reviews and
ratings of the movie from public view if
you're not registered with letterbox all
reviews of the movie are completely
hidden from site and the rating bar
that's displayed to showcase the average
score of a film has been removed
unregistered viewers are unable to see
any reviews of the film both negative
and positive if you're registered with
letterbox the site only allows you to
view the reviews of people in your
friends list who've already reviewed the
movie if you go to the review screen as
a registered user it shows no reviews
for the film despite the fact that over
1700 registered users have watched the
movie as of this writing
on the reviews of page for what is a
woman you're only allowed to
view the star ratings people have given
the film but you're not allowed to read
the reviews of the movie unless you go
directly to the user's page and read the
review every other movie on the site has
the listed ratings page recent reviews
and popular reviews shown without
restriction
this is just
it's just i mean it's remarkable isn't
it
they are so terrified of this movie they
really are i i don't think
i know i'm kind of biased and i'm i'm
promoting the movie but
has any movie in recent history
made them this afraid like have they
ever has this ever happened to any other
movie
they're going this far out of their way
to make sure that you can't talk about
it
censoring the review the user reviews of
the movie that's how afraid they are of
this film
it is really incredible
and if you haven't watched the movie yet
and subscribe to dailywire and or go to
what is woman.com and subscribe to watch
the movie this is all the more reason
why you ought to do that okay one other
story i really wanted to mention
here this is from the post-millennial um
in a uh an article written by ashley
saint-claire it says a family in
california is suing metta that's the now
the parent company for facebook for
their daughter's eating disorder and
self-harm following her addiction to
meta's platforms the family of alexis
spence is looking to hold the social
media giant accountable for severe
mental health struggles they claim are a
result of metta's deliberate efforts to
get pre-teens addicted to their products
one group out of seattle the social
media victims law center has taken on
alexis alexa spence's case to sue met on
behalf of the uh young girl for allowing
her and counsel the children to access
products which meta knows are addictive
harmful and dangerous
um
the family says that their once
confident and happy daughter alexis
began developing signs of depression and
anxiety shortly after secretly opening
an instagram account at just 11 years
old through instagram she was exposed to
a plethora of dangerous content
including sexually explicit messages and
photos from adults as well as
solicitation of sexual acts at 12 years
old
spence was drawing pictures of herself
next to her phone with a thought bubble
above her head saying things like kill
yourself
and stupid fat worthless spence
continues to have a severe decline in
her mental health resulting in a
life-threatening eating disorder and
suicidal ideations all of which her
family attributes to social media
addiction and the content instagram
exposed her too now
uh
a couple things here
i am fully on board for holding these
social media platforms accountable
especially for the damage they're doing
to kids fully on board for that
and they are knowingly
willingly intentionally
damaging kids in this room they're
trying to get kids addicted to this
stuff they know how bad it is for them
and so if anything that can be done to
hold them accountable i think is great
sue them whatever you can do
fully on board for that absolutely
but then there's the other part of this
there's the other piece of the puzzle
the other part of the story
which is that
this is an 11 year old girl
who has access to instagram now it does
say it's not clear in the article
how she accessed instagram it says that
she opened okay she opened the uh
the account secretly her parents didn't
know about it
so it's not as though this isn't as bad
as parents who even know that their very
young kids are on social media and are
okay with it
but then you have to ask well how how
did she get on instagram
and i think we can assume based on
context here that she got on instagram
because she was given a phone
um
now it's possible she could have opened
an instagram account some other way you
know maybe she used a friend's phone she
used the computer at school
something like that if there's some kind
of family desktop in the house maybe she
went there so we don't know exactly but
it seems like especially given the fact
that she's drawing pictures you know
with her she's drawing pictures of her
sitting sitting next to her phone which
tells me that she has a phone okay so if
if that's correct
then these parents gave their daughter
a phone at 11 years old
with open access to the internet
open enough that she could open an
instagram account
like they didn't even block the social
media platforms
which at a minimum if you're going to
give your kid a phone with internet
access you can go in
and block
certain websites
to block any website you want so it
seems they didn't even do that
but a better option
instead of giving your kid a phone and
then blocking websites
better option is just don't give her the
phone
and if you really feel like your child
needs a phone for safety because this is
this is one of the excuses parents
always give
so i need a way to get in touch with my
with my kid
now of course for most of human history
uh
parents did not have a way to
immediately get in touch with their kid
every second of the day by calling them
on some device they carry around their
pockets and kids you know most kids
survive just fine without it but if you
feel like you need that then you can
give your kid a phone that has no
internet capability whatsoever they do
make phones like that
so you really got to go out of your way
and invest the money
in one of these devices that's going to
do such incredible damage to your child
so i'm i'm a little bit split on this
i'm of two minds on one hand yes hold
the social media platforms accountable
on the other hand the parents here
are potentially looking to rake in
millions of dollars in a lawsuit
yet they're the ones who gave a phone to
their kid
okay the blame starts with the parents
and then you go to the social media
platforms
and this is not like 50 blame it's not
worth dividing up blame it's 100 blame
goes to everybody
the social media platforms big tech
companies they're 100 to blame for the
things that they do
but you as a parent are 100 to blame for
the decisions that you make including
giving your kid a phone it's just
inexcusable there's no good reason for
it
and i i
i say this somewhat rhetorically because
i can't understand but
in a certain sense i can't understand
why parents continue to do this knowing
the damage that it does
here's what we know
you give your 11 year old a smartphone
with internet access
there's no positive result okay nothing
good's going to come of that it's not
going to enhance their lives in any way
it's not going to make them more
fulfilled more happy
it's not going to make them better
people there's zero chance that that
happens
it will do damage it's just a matter of
how much damage will it do and so you
give them the phone with internet access
hoping that uh it's not as much damage
as
it could be
so now you're just playing damage
control at best a lot of parents don't
even do damage control they just give
the phone internet access and then say
oh go ahead go up to your room
kids sitting up in their room hours a
day
it's it's it's night time your kid went
to bed they've got a phone with them you
have no idea what they're doing
you you know this this world of insanity
and filth
that's opened up to them and they've got
their phone in their beds with them at
night and you're well you just go to
sleep not know
i wouldn't be able to sleep at night
if i knew that my child had access to
this kind of stuff and i have no idea
what he's doing i wouldn't be able to i
wouldn't be able to sleep
i would say to these parents literally
how do you sleep at night i don't know
how you do it i wouldn't be able to
if you spent any time on the internet
you know what's out there you know how
easy it is to access
oh but if we don't give our kid a phone
with internet access then they'll be
they'll be weird
you know it'll be weird because all
their friends have it
so
you're the parent
yeah it will seem weird and their
friends will think they're weird so what
why does that matter to you you're the
parent yeah it's okay for a kid
to be so invested in that and in
conforming and
and the thing that they fear most of all
is that they'll be seen as weird by
their peers so i understand that your
kid
as a child who's immersed in this world
and can't see past the nose on
her face that for her that's the worst
thing in the world to be judged by her
peers but you're the adult you're
supposed to know better
you know that she's gonna grow up and
and she's gonna gradually leave
school behind and none of this is going
to matter anymore
it's uh it's unbelievable to me
stop giving your phones to your kids
please i beg you all parents
let's get now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
death from above says matt you
misgendered natalie nguyen you referred
to natalie as her when in fact natalie
is a hymn which would add more context
to his position on drag queens and kids
uh i yeah i was just going based on the
name always a risky move these days i
had no idea
um
but thanks for the correction mel says i
thought you were unfair to professor
dave he was a lot more objective than
you make him seem he even says in his
video that males have an advantage over
biological females in sports
yeah he does say that in the video now
in my response to so-called professor
dave and i'm starting very much to
suspect that he's not a real professor
though who knows i mean there are plenty
of real professors as we discovered who
are um idiots but
uh i was responding to his criticisms of
the right
and then he does have a little portion
at the end where he criticizes the left
on the gender issue mostly criticizes
them essentially for not being liberal
enough but he does mention
he does say this yeah that um
he admits that biological males have
advantages over biological females and
sports now am i supposed to give him
what am i get my pat on the back give
him a cookie because he said that
you have no choice but to admit that
there's no way around it you have to
admit
it but
where does he go from there he says in
the video that uh biological males have
advantages over females
but he does not say
that they should therefore be excluded
from female sports and he uh he in his
cop-out is that well i don't care about
sports so why it's not up to me what
what team they play on
what an absolute so
you know that it's unfair but you're
still unwilling to say that they
shouldn't be allowed to do it
well that doesn't uh that doesn't make
it more objective it just makes him more
of an intellectual coward i did him a
favor by not mentioning that
all right jake says
matt i'm curious about your vision for
what is a woman what do you ultimately
hope it achieves
you know what i hope for the film i hope
that it makes itself irrelevant that's
my ultimate hope my ultimate hope
is that what is a woman will be totally
irrelevant at some point in the future
um i wanted to get to a point where
people see this movie and they're
it's like a snapshot of a
bygone era it's it's like an
anthropological study for them it's a
time capsule where they can look back
and and see it as what the hell was
happening back then that's what i hope
um
i hope for a time when
nothing in the film is remotely relevant
to anybody
because we don't live in a totally
insane society anymore
uh rose says i watched your documentary
matt and you interviewed sane
psychiatrists and therapists as a
therapist i need to know does that give
you some hope that some of us are
fighting back and not going with the
insanity to poison and destroy kids that
definitely it gives me some hope that
there are some sane good psychiatrists
and therapists out there
um
but unfortunately as you know rose
there's not enough
and even to the even from the sane ones
that i talked to like they all told me
that um
that the deck is stacked against them
and just by talking about this publicly
they've
offered themselves up to be sort of
exiled from the industry
which is good it takes a lot of courage
to speak out but it just shows you that
uh how deep the rot is within these
institutions
so i have some hope in some individual
people in these institutions who have a
lot of courage and are willing to say
the truth uh but institutionally i have
like no hope
for the institutions
let's see
sam says kelly j keane reviewed your
film and called herself a femaleist
rather than a feminist because she's
interested in defending females what do
you think of that i know you're not a
fan of feminism
uh female list is a interesting
you know interesting option interesting
variation i just don't think you need an
ist see i don't have a i don't feel the
need for any ist or ism when it comes to
this
um when it comes to my
defense of biological reality
i guess i am now a biologist because i'm
talking about this but i don't really
think i need an ister-ism or a label to
attach to that it's just uh like don
suker the star wars shop owner said in
the film it's just common sense
common senseism how about that maybe
we'll go with that
um
and andrew says i have another criticism
of professor dave if gender can only be
understood through complex neurobiology
why are we allowing kids to decide their
own gender instead of only allowing
postgraduate college students
uh yes
exactly that's one of the many i mean
here's one of the problems when you're
trying to respond to the gender
ideologues and you know and i try to be
as thorough as possible pick it apart
piece by piece but everything they say
is just
is is layered in so much contradiction
and incoherence that um you're always
gonna you know you're gonna miss a few
points and that's one of them very good
point though well as uh as you've heard
what is a woman is a huge success it's
something that i mean it's it's
certainly exceeded my own expectations
for what would happen with this film and
it's only a week and a half into it so
first of all thank you for that we
couldn't do it without you guys without
without our uh subscribers and also um
this weekend is the pride parade in dc
so we've got some uh we've got some
some things in store we had sky writers
at the women's march and this weekend
we're going to have a mobile truck
showing clips from what is a woman at
the pride parade in dc i'm very excited
about that because i think they're
probably a lot of people at the pride
parade who haven't had a chance to see
the movie yet
and so we want to make sure that they
see it it's just very nice of us i mean
we're kind of giving this away for free
and you know in the process we're
changing the gender ideology
conversation and fighting back in the
culture which has never been more
important and more relevant so celebrate
pride month and the pride parade by
watching what is a woman and if you've
already seen it then make sure to tell
your friends to watch as well share it
with them also help us strengthen our
stand against the radical trans ideology
agenda by sharing your support of the
film on social media and encouraging
others to watch at whatisawoman.com so
go to whatiswoman.com to become a member
and watch the film today now lets get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation uh it
begins with the age-old wisdom first
uttered i believe in a greek epic poem
that um one who goes woke shall thus
soon as we know go broke old navy was
the latest company to learn this ancient
truism with their failed experiment in
plus-sized clothing sorry not plus-sized
clothing this is inclusive sizing is
what they call that's the new pc term of
art because clothing must be inclusive
it must include skinny people
normal-sized people fat people morbidly
obese people
people for whom morbid obesity is a
weight loss goal like everyone must be
included a clothing company cannot
really show off its virtue and its
commitment to inclusivity unless it
sells pants that could double as boat
covers okay and and even if nobody can
actually fit in those pants and so
nobody's going to buy them
you could still show off the pants fly
them like an enormous flag to signal
your wokeness to the world
it's a good way to earn applause it's
just not a great way to earn money
and as old navy discovered you kind of
need to earn money if you want your
business to survive here's the wall
street journal it says old navy set out
to make clothe clothes shopping more
inclusive for women of all body types it
ended up with too many extra small and
extra large items and too few of the
rest a mismatch that frustrated
customers and contributed to fail to
falling sales and a management shakeup
i saw a pause there for a second
um
why just women
see we so they they did the inclusive
sizing for
women well old baby it's better while
since i've been in an old navy but they
do sell men's clothing too don't they
i know they at least sell cargo shorts
for men
so we note once again how the body
positivity stuff focus focuses almost
entirely on women this is why there are
no plus-sized male models have you
noticed that
nobody is ever using men in their
fatnesses beautiful campaigns when's the
last time you saw a dude with a huge
potbelly on a billboard
with the words love yourself or be
confident at any size or whatever else
never
unless it's a pregnant man okay then you
might see it but otherwise you don't see
it
and that's because it doesn't exist
that's because nobody cares actually if
men hate themselves indeed men are
supposed to hate themselves unless
they're gay or they belong to some other
victim group
left-wing victimology means that
nothing they say can ever be applied
consistently that's the point there are
no universal principles in leftist
thought which is why most men are
excluded from most of this but back to
the article it says billed as one of the
biggest launches in the brand's history
old navy and august began offering all
women's clothing sizes in size 0 to 30
and x extra small to 4x making it one of
the first retailers to play such a big
bet
on inclusive sizing a big big bet i
don't know if that was a pun it did away
with separate petite and plus size
departments and grouped all sizes of
each style together mannequins and
varying body shapes displayed the new
wears all sizes of a style were priced
the same
which was a break with an industry
practice in which retailers charge more
for larger sizes this is the largest
integrated launch in the brand's history
and an important growth driver for the
business for years to come according to
the
gap chief executive
sonia singal
now
just to note here plus size clothing
costs more because it requires more
material to make
and clothing is separated into different
sections because it's easier for
customers to find what they're looking
for that way
and generally clothing stores will have
much fewer options in the 3x and 4x
sizes because there are far fewer people
who fit those sizes now i'm no business
guru okay nobody's inviting me to be an
investor on shark tank or anything but i
do at least know that if you create more
expensive products charge less for them
make the customer experience more
frustrating intentionally make it harder
for customers to find what they want and
you intentionally stock more products
that fewer of your customers want to buy
you will lose money
and it turns out that old navy did going
back to the article says soon after
however old navy's sales started to
nosedive last month nancy green the
chain's president and chief executive
stepped down after less than two years
running the brand gap warned that sales
for the spring quarter would fall short
of expectations in part due to the
troubles at old navy the extended sizes
were the culprit according to current
and former employees stores were selling
out of the middle sizes and were stuck
with piles of very small and very large
sizes the employees said to clear out
the excess goods old navy put a large
quantity of women's clothing on sale
this spring which contrasts with other
retailers that have held the line on
discounting because of strong demand and
supply chain challenges
now ultimately old navy announced that
it would be removing the inclusive sizes
from 75 of its stores
and this has enraged body positivity
advocates who as always um are not going
to give you points for trying
old navy tried to appease them
lost millions of dollars and then had to
backtrack
but the body positivity folks demanded
old navy fully drive itself into
bankruptcy because that's what makes
them feel better about themselves
for example one fat liberation quote
unquote advocate on tick tock actually
checked to see how many old navy stores
no longer sell plus size clothing and in
the process she uncovered a major
scandal watch this
remember this statement that old navy
keeps saying that they're only cutting
back plus sizes in 75 stores in the u.s
i may have done something bad
this is what it looks like if the plus
size are carried there see how it says
shop plus women's here and see how this
one has nothing
i made an excel spreadsheet
and
i'm going through each state and you can
see
there's a good number that don't carry
plus sizes so far i have only gotten
through six states
but there's a total of a hundred that do
not carry plus sizes more than 75.
it's gonna take me a while but
should i keep going
sure why not you know nothing better to
do apparently uh continue making your
spreadsheet maybe um
you know consider hopping on a treadmill
while you're tabulating the results
i don't say that to be rude okay there's
an important point important point here
this person is going through all of this
effort
to find stores with plus size clothing
spending hours researching every old
navy location in the country making
spreadsheets filming tick tock videos
she's devoted her life to fat liberation
she's doing all of this when she could
simply go on a diet and none of this
would be an issue
see the real way to achieve fat
liberation is to eat a salad
now of course you can't even point this
out anymore without sounding like a
bully that's because
we consider it bullying to do or say
anything that might cause another person
to engage in any sort of honest
self-criticism
well depending on who the other person
is as noted no principle is universal in
our culture but if the person's in a
favored class you must not ever cause
them to look critically at themselves or
at their own behavior
you can be guilty of bullying in this
regard even if you're not trying so for
example this is pretty
incredible listen to this
um
sydney sweeney is an actress i think and
she showed up to the mtv awards this
past weekend because apparently the mtv
awards happened this past weekend and
like so many young women at so many mtv
award ceremonies before her sweeney was
dressed in clothing that barely
qualifies as clothing at all she was
scantily clad in other words and now
she's being criticized criticized
largely by young leftists on social
media
for her immodest attire
they have a problem with her lack of
modesty
not because they care about modesty per
se
but because her physical appearance
makes them feel bad about themselves so
here's the yahoo article about the
controversy it says although sweeney
pulls it off beautifully reluctance from
onlookers to praise the outfit has less
to do with styling than it does the
messaging about beauty and body
standards quote
no shade to beautiful sydney but i'm sad
we're seeing more of this ultra low rise
waist and ultra flat tummy look again
according to one person on instagram
someone else said
so coveted yet unachievable for so many
of us with different builds
someone else said watch body positivity
go down the drain once the low ride
fashion takes over again
and someone else said low rise never
again young generations learn from the
past
don't ruin your body
similar sentiments have been expressed
by body acceptance advocates who have
watched the micro mini skirts comeback
the trend is among others from the early
2000s that have seen a resurgence
however
it is seemingly the most exclusive quote
this set is created with this very thin
body in mind it's not created for plus
and so that in and of itself is
frustrating according to uh
some co-founder of something called
power of plus
quote a lot of it too feels very
glorifying of a body type that we've
been working against actively for many
years now
wait hold on a second
we've been working against
a body type
i thought we're supposed to accept all
body types see they're criticizing not
just the the outfit but the body type
the body itself
they don't have a problem with the way
the clothing looks
they certainly don't have a problem with
with women wearing skimpy outfits if
that was lizzo dressed like that at the
awards ceremony
which she probably was if she was there
they'd be tripping over themselves to
extol her beauty and boldness
i mean lizzo could and i think she's
actually done this just walk down the
red carpet completely nude and they
would be saying this is the greatest
thing they've ever seen in their lives
no they have a problem
when it comes to this woman
with that kind of body
namely an in shape healthy body because
it makes them feel bad about their
bodies
and anything that makes them feel bad is
bad
even some other person's actual
entire body can be bad if looking at it
makes them feel bad
this by the way is the reason why
left-wing trans activists have such
disdain for women
because actual women remind them of what
they'll never be and that makes them
feel bad and so women are bad and
they're morally entitled to treat them
that way
this is the madness that inevitably
results from emphasizing self-perception
over reality
when we declare that affirmation is
necessary for emotional well-being
and that emotional well-being is just as
important if not more important than
physical well-being
this is where we end up
soon they're going to be strapping
skinny women onto gurneys and
force-feeding them cinnabons just to
make sure that everyone is equally fat
and unhealthy
so that none of us ever have to feel bad
about being fat and unhealthy ourselves
this is the the mentality that old navy
tried to cater to
and they paid the expected price
that's why they are today canceled
and will do it for us today and for the
week
talk to you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily
dailywire 2022. hey everybody this is
andrew clavin host of the andrew clavin
show you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood but on the andrew clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me andrew
clavin